should accept yourself just the way you
are what does that say about who I
should become is that just now off the
table because I'm already good enough in
every way so am I done or something get
the hell up get your act together adopt
some responsibility put your life
together develop a vision unfold all
those manifold possibilities that lurk
within be a force for good in the world
and that'll be the adventure of your
life
[Music]
your identity is the manner in which
you're situated in Social space now it's
also something internal and
psychological it is who you experience
yourself as being but that's not all of
it you exist in relationship to your
intimate partner you exist in
relationship to your family you exist in
relationship to your neighborhood in
your community in your town in your
state and your country and your
Transcendent ideals of one form or
another and every single one of those
aspects is part of identity and the idea
that that can all be reduced to
something internal and subjective it's
the ultimate extension of the idea that
the only person who can say what I am is
me one of the things I come across in my
child he's he's 10. and he came home and
he was explaining to me about his uh
friend who transitioned and is now a
female so his first question of course
was did this child grow a vagina over
the summer his friends are confused now
does that make me gay that I like them
what do you mean can I grow a vagina
over the summer how do I know I'm not
next and my son asked me well how do I
know if I'm a boy and I was just like
this is scary and it is disorienting our
children
[Music]
hello everybody I'm here talking today
with Sarah Stockton Sarah is a therapist
and she was interviewed for Matt Walsh's
documentary what is a woman and she's
been involved
um well in those sorts of issues for
quite a long time I watched the
documentary and was struck by her
testimony and she also reached out to me
wrote me a letter about how things had
unfolded for her and her therapeutic
practice over the last five ten years
and we've decided jointly that a further
conversation might be useful publicly
and also well useful to people who are
family members of
adolescents
suffering from gender dysphoria but also
useful for therapists who are torn
ethically
about how to proceed
properly in this fraught gender
affirming
therapy environment and so thank you
very much for agreeing to talk to me
today I'm sure that your decision to
make your concerns public has been very
hard on you
um I I have some real sympathy for that
why don't you start by telling everybody
how it is that you came to be involved
well in this entire
Quagmire but also why you decided to
participate in the Matt Walsh
documentary which I'm also sure took a
fair bit of soul searching so let's why
don't you lay out the story yes and I
think we'll talk a little bit more about
my experience but I started in 2008
working in a special uh transgender team
and that's where I started my expertise
and Specialty in that I had participated
and co-authored the transgender
assessment that mental health
professionals use to
assess transgender youth Readiness to
begin hormone treatment or medical
treatment I published that and I had
worked a great deal of my first part of
my career
traveling teaching doctors teaching
schools how to change their practice for
to be more gender affirming care that is
a terminology that is more recent that
was not what I was using back then
then I sort of
came across in my practice a lot of
concerns around this being 15 years in
and treating a lot of sexual issues I
had some concerns with how it was
developmentally being presented to our
children
and so I kind of just
stopped doing that specialty and I went
on
to just doing sex and then as life would
have it I have children who are in grade
school and coming across these issues
and children coming into my practice
with questions that
I can only understand that they would
have because of this presentation being
even
allowed to be taught to them at such a
young age and so what actually happened
was a client sent me a clip of Matt
Walsh on Dr Phil I'd never heard of Matt
Walsh prior to that and I just happened
to message Matt Walsh and told him hey
I'm
I was a part of writing the assessment
and I have some concerns and he
contacted me right away and I had flown
out within a week and did the
documentary and spoke with him all right
so we'll talk about about a little bit
about how that's impacted your life
let's go back what's your educational
background like how did you train as a
therapist yes so I have a bachelor's
degree in Psychology and then I went to
Syracuse University where I received my
master's degree in marriage and family
therapy
okay and then how did you get involved
this was back in 2008 you published a
paper that was devoted towards
assessment was it specifically
assessment of gender dysphoria what what
exactly was the paper and how did you
get involved in that particular issue
why did that attract your attention Okay
it's very good question so in my school
where we were going
we were the top place for actually
developing the hormone assessment to
start
adults on hormone replacement uh therapy
so the professors there were
very much in charge of being the first
ones to ever be giving these letters
making these letters so
we were introduced to you had an
opportunity to get on what they would
call a transgender team and you would
have to interview to be on this team and
I will be honest with you I'm a young
22 year old and my interest is in Sex
and that was obviously a introduction
into a complex
thing that people were dealing with so
you would get onto this transgender team
and we would have special training about
body dysphoria gender dysphoria uh what
are the sexual implications and then we
were required to
see these patients at our clinic and get
supervision weekly what we what at this
time they were really recognizing was
was would there be a better
outcome for these individuals if there
was early intervention medically
therefore we the responsibility of my
group was to take the original
assessment that was used for adults and
turn it into a comprehensive assessment
to evaluate uh child's Readiness along
with their family because this was a
systemic program
to see if they understood the
implications of starting hormone
blockers or home hormone replacement
surgery okay so so let me see if I've
got this straight so when you were about
22 you were pursuing your bachelor's
degree you had an interest in the
broader domain of sexual behavior and
that was part of what was driving you
towards a clinical path you started
working with adults who were transsexual
or transgender and how old would have
they been on average
oh it was all at all ages but I would
say you're typically dealing with 30s
40s and 50s
okay okay so these are people in early
middle age let's say and and so they're
they're being assessed for suitability
for medical transition which would begin
with hormonal transformation and then
the idea emerges well you know there are
30 or 40 or 50. it's pretty late in life
to begin such a transformation would it
have been better for them let's say have
they uh discovered this route earlier
and if it was better
how what would better look like and how
that might be how might that be brought
down the age chain so that it's uh made
available for
people who are very young of course then
that raises the Specter of how young and
also the problem of differential
diagnosis now let's let's make a slight
foray here
um into us into a different area so
from what I understand of the clinical
literature with regards to
gender identity dysphoria there are two
essential manifestations of what becomes
something approximating transmitism or
transsexual
um orientation and one of those is
relatively late onset and people like uh
what's his name uh Zucker Ken Zucker his
hypothesis was there are the auto
gynophilic late onset transsexual types
who tend to be men who tend to dress up
in women's clothing uh generally uh
Force for essentially sexual purposes
and they're dealing with issues well
that are difficult to understand but
might have to do if you're thinking
about it from a psychoanalytic
perspective might have to do with the
difficulty of integrating cross sexual
personality elements into their
personality that takes a sexual root
among the autoginophilic types and
they're a separate group from
children who develop
body dysmorphia or gender identity
trouble very early and they tend to be
let's say feminine boys feminine by
temperament or masculine girls masculine
by temperament which is maybe also why a
very large number of autistic girls seem
to be caught up in this and they're
they're a diagnostically distinct group
and conflating them isn't helpful that's
an additional complication these people
that you were seeing in their early
middle age
do you think that they what What
proportion of them do you think were
temperamentally
um
ill-fitted let's say to their biological
sex masculine girls or feminine boys and
how many of them do you think at that
time this is back in 2008 fit more into
the auto gynophilic category and or did
you make that distinction at that time
so I'm and this is one of the reasons Dr
Peterson why I'm having this
conversation with you I I have to be
honest
um being taught under this terminology
it wasn't until I was in my practice on
my own for many years that I was even
introduced to the terminology
Otto gonophilia so I can promise you
that that in schools right now they're
not being taught that they are not
understood that and it took so I mean I
think one of the really unique things
about my life was that I had the
opportunity to work with
cross-dressers which
really showed me the difference between
what we're calling
body dysphoria and gender dysphoria and
the erotic nature of it and not only
that I was introduced to
um a client who in his late 70s
actually
um had his penis amputied and it was a
really unique case because he would have
what we would understand his body
Integrity disorder he grew up on a farm
in Arkansas and really uh hated getting
up early and having to do all the work
as a male would have to do
his cousin ends up getting his her arm
amputed off and therefore does not have
to do a lot of work on the farm this
really impacts him throughout his life
he becomes engineer as children what not
but he has an extreme dis pleasure with
the fact that
he doesn't have something wrong with him
that would stop him and he decided that
that needs to be his penis and he went
to Philadelphia and asked to have the
surgery and they are said you will
you're not trans
and he was like okay but I dislike this
body part of mine and he took a pen and
put it up his penis and let it go to
gangrene he was under no influence of
alcohol or drugs
and ends up at the hospital and does get
his
penis amputee and I was called in
because they there was no uh homicidal
no suicidal ideation no no Under the
Influence this was the case where he was
like I just do not like this body part
now I did a lot of Assessments around
being trans this was an agenda thing
this so that really showed me of like
whoa there is a lot of things going on
for people and the outcome of
I don't feel as a child
is is very complex and and that we
weren't I was not yeah yeah well that's
that well okay okay well that okay so
that's very much worth delving into I
mean
there's a very
um cardinal
temptation
for people who are wading into extremely
complex territory to assume that the
territory is a lot simpler than they
think to assume the problem is
unidimensional and then worse to assume
that the that the treatment is simple
and unidimensional and certainly if
you're wandering into the territory of
paraphilic sexual attraction let's say
to say you're in a Minefield is to say
almost nothing because the limitlessness
of human sexual pathology is enough to
produce post-traumatic stress disorder
in anyone who studies it in any depth
and so and and you said that when you
were educated that that all of this was
collapsed into something that's like a
hyper oversimplification right and then
there's a moralistic element to it too I
mean Zucker is a really good example
because Ken Zucker was probably the
world's foremost leading Authority on
gender dysphoria and auto gynophilia
which he separated very carefully
clinically he ran the gender dysphoria
clinic in Toronto and was eventually
hounded out of his life by gender
affirming activists and what Zucker
showed
were well apart from the distinction
between the auto gynophilic types and
then the kids who had uh cross sex
temperament he showed that
if you left kids who had body dysmorphia
issues alone 90 percent of them would
settle into their biological identity by
the time they were 18 or 19. but he also
showed quite clearly that the early
onset gender dysphoria kids were much
more likely to be gay about 80 percent
of them adopted a homosexual or
manifested a homosexual orientation and
one of the Terrible
inspectors that that entices upward out
of the crypt is the fact that the gender
surgical Enterprise hormone therapy
puberty blockers all of that
overwhelmingly targets the gay
population and that's a very interesting
issue on the political front because in
principle there's an LGBT Alliance and
Community except that the interests of
the transsexual types especially the
radicals couldn't be more diametrically
opposed to the interest of the gay
community assuming such things exist if
it was designed to be antithetical okay
so now you were placed in a situation
where as a therapist you were trained in
a uni-dimensional analysis of the gender
dysphoria problem and then you started
to develop the assessment guidelines
correct and did you do that as a
bachelor's student or as a master's
student no it was with Masters and PhD
students
okay okay and so walk me through the
development of the assessment process
and tell me what you were thinking then
about assessment and about and what you
think about it now and I'm also
interested too in why it was that it was
through your interest in sex that you
became interested in being a therapist
yes I mean I think I have a little bit
of um
I you know comfort with discomfort or
the uh
things that people don't want to talk
about so I think that really hit for me
and one of the things I reflect on
because I kind of am embarrassed that I
used to present on this topic but I have
a medical condition I have a blood
clotting disorder and
from the outside many people can't see
that and I when I would present with
Physicians around how to get their
practice to be more gender affirming I
would share that that you know
you don't know what it's like to have an
illness that perhaps people don't know
from the outside and that really helped
me relate to these children I think of
like you're presenting with something
that maybe from the outside no one
understands but from the inside that
it's there but but now understanding my
diagnosis can medically
have evidence right it's there's
chemicals that can be
diagnostically looked at and
that's not the case for the children so
I will say when we started doing this it
wasn't a lot of children there wasn't
like hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
like there are now that need to be seen
these were children like you said that
were presented pretty young presenting
pretty young with
aversions to their body right and these
are at this time too we don't have
Internet we don't have Internet in the
same capacity Tick Tock right yeah they
don't know what they're talking about so
they're not telling us I'm transgender
these were parents bringing kids to us
saying something's going on this kid is
saying this you know my penis shouldn't
be here and they're three
um they are you know have
consistently shown a certain way so this
is what this is the cases that we were
presented with and working with and we
this assessment was supposed to be
probably about a year to a two-year
assessment right to fully assess the six
domains of Early Childhood we would look
at so how was their gender presented in
early childhood does the way they
present and discuss it connect with
their with their family so that was a
big part of double checking was wasn't
just what the children said it was what
the family were presenting as well of
what they've witnessed going on with
their child
physical history sexual
um context School context and one of the
biggest
areas and domains that are no longer
discussed and I and this is where
developmentally I was really concerned
is future expectations
I mean
when I was doing it back then these
children understood they were never
going to be that gender so if they were
they were going to be a trans male and I
think that distinction was significant
whereas now it is magical like no I'll
be a male because I said it
and one of the things that I can't
assess as easily is do they know the
implications to what they're doing
back then I guess well even as adults we
rarely know the implications of what
we're doing so it's very very difficult
for especially hyper-confused kids when
you were developing these assessments
okay so first of all you said we've kind
of talked about why the idea of early
assessment had emerged on the landscape
right you're dealing with older people
and the question arose perhaps they
should have been dealt with more
efficiently when they were young and so
you could see a Trail opening up in that
direction now you're talking to kids who
have body dysmorphia that their parents
are bringing to the attention of
therapists and of course that's a snake
pit too because there's endless numbers
of reasons why children might develop
body dysmorphia some of them would have
to do with temperament body mismatch but
there's all sorts of other possibilities
too that they're responding to
unconscious prompts on the part of their
parents that would be particularly true
if they have narcissistic or
Psychopathic parents and that's
increasingly the case for the kids who
manifest extremely early signs of
so-called gender dysphoria now because
their mothers often are making a display
of their compassion by using their
children's illness and their
compassionate response to it as a what
would you call it as a as a goad to
their narcissistic display yes you can
see that sort of thing emerging
everywhere and so that's a bloody
catastrophe and then you have autistic
kids who don't fit in very well
especially on the female side and they
do think in some ways more like males do
because they're more thing oriented and
you have the possibility of the early
development of psychosis and then you
have the difficulty of distinguishing
the Children's Fantasy play from genuine
concerns about their identity like it's
it requires unbelievably careful
multiple multiply dimensioned diagnostic
analysis and you said you know your
vision at least to begin with was that
there was no fast route let's say to
puberty blockers or hormone treatment
you were looking at at least a one to
two year assessment and I would think
given my clinical experience that one
year of weekly meetings with someone
competent would be minimally necessary
to sort any of that out and so and that
was your vision and now it's three and
2008 it's three sessions
it's three sessions now that's the
standard okay so tell us why you believe
that to be the case what have you
observed well I mean and tell us about
Planned Parenthood too yeah I think a
lot of things I mean one of the things I
will say it was obvious that this
assessment was to get them on hormone
blockers to either you know pause to see
if they're if this is what they want and
and that was the the goal of our
assessment and one of the things
well to get them on hormone blockers or
to determine if that was the appropriate
path
I I want I want to say the first one but
I will tell you as soon as there was
guidelines people knew what they wanted
so they came in and just knew that I was
step one to get where they want so I've
already right okay okay well that's very
interesting eh because you see you run
into US you run to a therapeutic problem
there right away is because people
especially if they're deeply confused
will clutch at straws and if they feel
that they've now got the answer to all
of their problems then the next thing
they're going to think is well let's get
this show on the road right
hey Reagan I know you're picky when it
comes to skin care products so tell me
what did you think of genucel skin care
that's exactly right Garrett I'm the
type of person who wants to know exactly
what ingredients I'm using in my
skincare routine which is why I'm loving
genucel their products are made with
antioxidants and formulated by
compounding pharmacist and they're all
about preventative skin care with Summer
coming up around the corner I'll be
using genucel's powerful retinol
alternative which is safe to use on your
skin in the hot summer sun they also
have a dark spot corrector which helps
reduce the appearance of dark marks and
sunspots right now you can get them both
in genucel's most popular package at
genucel.com Jordan you heard it here
first don't miss out on this amazing
deal just in time for warmer days ahead
go to genucel.com Jordan to get 70 off
their most popular package every Aura
subscription includes a luxury gift box
with two free Springtime Essentials
that's two free gifts plus free shipping
go to genucel.com
Jordan genucel.com Jordan
now the unfortunate truth of the matter
is is that if you're caught in an
extremely complex psychological
situation it might take a year of
painful analysis and introspection just
to figure out what the hell is going on
and it's not like that's calming in fact
at least temporarily it can make things
worse as you start to assess all the
familial pathology sometimes
multi-generational familial pathology
that's driving this kind of behavior
forward but your observation it was
interesting to watch you pause there
because your observation was well as
soon as this pathway became open
now there's pressure you can imagine
there's pressure from the clients to get
the show on the road but then there's
also pressure on the diagnostic and cost
side it's like well if really what we're
doing is facilitating transition why
don't we do that as efficiently as
possible and then you see the collapse
of what your one to two year assessment
into three sessions now I interviewed
Chloe Cole who's suing she's a d
transitioner who's initiated legal
action in the United States and when I
interviewed her I did something like a
modified clinical interview partly
because I wanted to see if anyone ever
even walked her through the basics of
what was wrong with her and the answer
was a hundred percent no so I told Chloe
for example she hit puberty pretty young
and I told her well
girls reliably experience an increase in
negative emotion at puberty and that
looks like it's pharmacological because
the big difference in neuroticism
between men and women doesn't emerge
until puberty and it probably emerges in
women because they become sexually
vulnerable because the change in body
size occurs at puberty so women are now
at a physical disadvantage they're
sexually vulnerable plus they're going
to have to take care of infants in all
likelihood at some point in their life
and so it makes sense for them to be
more sensitive to threat that produces a
spike in negative emotion and
with women in particular because women
are evaluated for their physical
appearance to a degree that isn't the
case for men although men are also
evaluated on that dimension
the probability that negative emotion
will take the form of concern about body
Images extraordinarily high in women and
so I told Chloe
especially if you hit puberty early I
said look the fact that you were unhappy
and concerned about your body when you
were nine because you were undergoing
puberty is entirely developmentally
normal and then she said something
extremely interesting to me she said uh
she had had fantasies when she was nine
or ten and starting to hit puberty that
she would end up if she was fortunate to
be a woman who looked something like Kim
Kardashian with that hyper feminine form
and of course that's been enhanced in
Kardashian's case and also celebrated
madly in the requisite social media and
Cole realized that she was going to have
a rather boyish figure and instead of
someone sitting down with her explaining
to her that that was perfectly fine and
that there's an incredibly wide range of
male uh what appreciation for variations
in the feminine form which is definitely
the case she developed the belief that
if she couldn't be you know Kim
Kardashian she'd never be an acceptable
woman or certainly not an ideal woman
she's also a bit autistic and had a hard
time getting along with girls and was
found it easier to get along with boys
and so she started to develop this
fantasy that
like your gentleman who decided that
he'd be better off without his penis he
she started to fantasize about the fact
that life would probably be better for
her if she was just a boy and then she
was put on the gender transformation
path really without a moment's
hesitation and she ended up with a
double mastectomy when she was I believe
it was when she was 15. and the wounds
from that surgery never properly healed
so that's her life low voice quite
masculinized possibly sterile although
that isn't necessarily the case
definitely while her breasts are
destroyed Beyond repair you know she
well it's a complete bloody catastrophe
and it's partly because
she was never assessed even remotely
competently not in the least
and so okay so now we see the collapse
of your one to two year assessment
you know which had as one of its
implicit motivations the bringing
forward of the possibility of puberty
blockers and gender and then and then
hormone transformation you see that
starting to be rushed as a consequence
of client demand but also as a
consequence of institutional demand
let's say absolutely so you start to see
that unfold
yes and once I see it unfold as if
there's step one two three four in order
to be
the next gender right so hormone
blockers surgeries
electrolysis you know that that will be
that's all the focus was on not even
just treating the gender dysphoria I
mean think I think one of the things
that we might talk about later is when
you talk about butchers and
and I think about all the
children's bodies that I've seen
butchered and also knowing about
trauma-informed care it's just really
alarming to me that we're having
therapists working with people who are
chopping off their body parts and we're
not even doing any trauma-informed care
around any sort of trauma that goes on
to your body and no there's no
connection to those body parts those
emphasis on what you did it's a very
dissociative disc detached way of going
forward and I I've seen a lot of
concerns so one of the things that
really surprised me in life was when I
met my first D transitioner and one of
the things that it was really surprising
about that was when they were my client
originally they had no gender dysphoria
they had no body dysphoria they moved
away to California and they were gay
and they transitioned and and fully
facial reconstruction I came back and I
didn't recognize them and they said they
made a mistake and I was like how did
this happen I I worked with you three
years I never heard you discuss body and
it's an option like you said about
modern day conversion therapy
that it would be probably just easier if
I was female instead of being gay and
they transitioned and they made a
mistake and that was my first like wow
this is happening to people who didn't
even have body dysphoria
as a child
[Music]
right right yeah well it's a it's a
moral Quagmire a you know the the
capital the world's capital for
sex
transformation surgery is Tehran
and the reason for that is the molas
there have decided that gay is not
acceptable
but maybe you're not gay or a girl if
you're a male homosexual say no you're
not gay you're a girl and then if you go
through with the surgical transformation
then that's ethically acceptable and the
consequence of that as I said is that
Tehran is now the world's capital for
gender transformation surgery and that
should really make us think like long
and hard right and so and the notion
that it's also very interesting to
speculate about why the delusion that
puberty blockers hormone treatment and
then surgery is going to be an easier
route forward the idea that people take
that for granted is also an indication
of stunning
um Diagnostic and assessment
insufficiency because I got I talked to
Abigail schreier about in detail about
the horrendous
complexity of well full surgical
transformation which first of all isn't
possible except in the most in the
shallowest possible manner I mean you
can build a man a vagina
that will function badly for sexual
purposes but it has none of the other
functions of the actual parts and it's
as if we reduce this is something I find
particularly reprehensible it's as if
we've reduced the concept of woman to
um whole usable for sexual activity
because nothing else is transformed in
the surgical procedure and that's a
pretty damn shallow definition of what
constitutes a woman and to brandish that
in front of desperate young people who
are confused beyond comprehension as a
solution to their psychological problems
well that's why I wrote that essay
butchers and Liars it's so it's so
perverse that it's almost
incomprehensible and it's a miracle of a
negative sort that we've actually got
ourselves in a situation where this is
not only the standard of care but it's
the mandated standard of care because
across jurisdictions around across
Jersey sections Across the Western World
increasingly if you're a therapist and
you don't affirm someone's identity
which could certainly mean within the
first three sessions then you're
actually on the hook for professional
malpractice and so that's just a
jaw-dropping transformation in standards
of therapeutic care and it's interesting
to see how that came about too because
it came up
at least in part as a consequence of
legislation that was hypothetically
designed to stop so-called conversion
therapy which was the therapeutic
practice that a tiny tiny minority of
people used many decades ago to try to
uh convince gay people that their
orientation should and could be
transformed but virtually no
therapists certainly no therapist I ever
met in my life practiced that it
certainly wasn't part of the standard
training protocol for any reasonably
well educated clinical psychologists and
so the idea that that was an issue was
just a complete bloody lie but
nonetheless jurisdictions all around the
world rushed in to show their what would
you call ethical superiority on the woke
front and mandated therapists adopt this
gender-affirming stance and so now you
were interested when you were younger in
helping people who had gender dysphoria
deal with it you know and so you were
tilted to some degree in the gender
affirmation Direction but what did you
see how did you see that grow and morph
across time
yeah I mean I think a lot of different
ways I mean one of the ways of just
again how people speak about it and I
don't want to I I hope no one hears
disrespect towards LGBT community I work
a great deal with them but I want to go
back to our Professional Standards just
this year we in my profession they
release a lgtp LG TV
plus guidelines
and I don't mean to be funny but that
plus really makes me nervous I don't
know what that means and I don't know
what the
protective class of that means I will
tell you that I have kids identifying as
as animals right those things are
happening it was a joke when we started
oh now you're going to have someone
identifying as a lamp right and I'm
telling you people are coming in with
the trans ageism is right there I mean
if you can feel like a boy if you can
feel like a boy you can feel like a
child and one of the things that
concerns me I'll just give you an
example the definition dead name I mean
since I started the terminologies
continued to change we we never called
it dead name before it was you know
birth name and that is very alarming to
me we are normalizing suicide I there is
you know we are killing a part of
ourselves
and by calling it stuff like that it is
very dangerous
um yeah well we're also we're also
valorizing the idea that you can alter
the past you can do it by force and you
can punish other people who won't do it
with you you know one of the reasons I
got banned from Twitter and I think it
was the primary reason
it's very difficult to tell these things
was because
hypothetically I dead named
Elliott page Ellen Page which I'm now
doing again by the way and uh
all right this whole notion of dead name
just came out of the Void as far as I
was concerned it's like well who the
hell came up with that idea why did it
all of a sudden become a cardinal
ethical sin and what the hell do you
mean that I can't refer to someone by
who they were and that that's now a
crime I just don't understand any of
this at all it's so utterly preposterous
that it's almost beyond comprehension
but but we're we're primed for this and
there's an underlying set of ideas that
have to do with the notion I guess we
could get into this to some degree as
well
so psychotherapists
have adopted this shallow idea
and I think the whole field of clinical
Endeavor is what would you say guilty on
this front that the only valid marker of
identity is subjective whim
and this is actually technically wrong
and good psychologists should have known
this because identity is a
multi-dimensional phenomena and so
and the left insists on this the left
insists for example that your identity
is partly a consequence of your group
affiliation but we could walk through
that your identity is the manner in
which you're situated in Social space
now it's also something internal and
psychological it is who you experience
yourself as being but that's not all of
it you exist in relationship to your
intimate partner you exist in
relationship to your family you exist in
relationship to your neighborhood in
your community in your town in your
state and your country and your
Transcendent ideals of one form or
another and every single one of those
aspects is part of identity and the idea
that that can be reduced well and then
there's the biological and physical
elements of identity as well the fact
that you have two eyes and not six for
example and that you have a biological
sex whether you like it or not and the
idea that that can all be reduced to
something internal and subjective is a
consequence of the derailment of a kind
of liberal Protestant ethos of
self-actualization you know it's it's
it's the ultimate extension of the idea
that the only person who can say what I
am is me and the problem with that is
that it's simply not true I mean when
you and I are sitting here talking
we have to modify our mutual identities
in accordance with our desire to have
the conversation and so identity is
always negotiated and the idea that it
can now just be established by
subjective Fiat and that that
establishment has the weight of the law
behind it is an inversion of absolutely
incomprehensible magnitude and it's
terrible for people who are confused
because they're going to Define
themselves subjectively in a manner that
is not going to be good for the more
sustainable in a social Community or
sustainable in the long run and I'm
absolutely
jaw dropped in my amazement with regards
to the cowardice of people on the
therapeutic front who should know better
than this and who do who are saying
absolutely nothing about it and just
going along with uh with the
catastrophic Flood now for some reason
like this really hit home for you you
said in the letter that you wrote me
that you read that article I wrote on
butchers and liars and that really
bothered you but you were already
bothered by what you'd seen why has this
bothered you so much that you've risked
well first of all you know you're doing
a an ideological inversion in some sense
right because you're moving away from
your initial set of presuppositions and
then you're exposing yourself to
tremendous professional Risk by going on
Walsh's dark by appearing in Walsh's
documentary and certainly by talking to
me like why the hell are you doing this
what why has this become such a irritant
to your conscience that you feel
compelled to take this risk
because like you said I I wasn't taught
correctly and I was taught very well in
my opinion to be informed and to give
ethical treatment and Do no harm
it wasn't until I was about 10 years in
that a parent came and handed me a piece
of paper and said the doc the medication
that you want to give your children my
my child is not FDA approved explain to
me why I should give my child an FDA
non-fda approved drug these hormone
blockers for children are still not FDA
approved
I didn't know that Jordan
I should have known that
oh wow yeah and
things like that really alarm me and I
will tell you having children and and
going through so many things one of the
things they like to say that just drives
me crazy is you are assigned at Birth
that is not true I have done IVF I know
the sex the of my child five days after
that sperm and egg meat it is not it is
observed it is observed at Birth if
anything it is not is not a sign so
children and teacher and teachers and
psychologists are are thinking that kids
come out very ambiguous and it's not
ambiguous that is a very rare thing
one of the things I come across in my
child he's he's 10. and he came home and
he was explaining to me about his uh
friend who transitioned and is now a
female
and I first of all he had a lot of
questions for me because he was going to
school with that child for many years so
his first question of course was did
this child grow a vagina over the summer
and that show that showed me a lot that
this isn't even being presented as no
this is a mental health problem that
this person is going and with or that
this is gender dysphoria and this is
what we're presenting it this is now a
female so
his friends are confused now does that
make me gay that I like them what do you
mean can I grow a vagina over the summer
how do I know I'm not next and my son
asked me well how do I know if I'm a boy
and I was just like
this is scary and it is disorienting our
children
and disoriented you couldn't you
couldn't possibly disorient children
more there isn't anything you could
possibly do to children I don't think
that confusing them about the difference
between up and down would be more
disorienting than confusing them about
the difference between male and female
and I say that partly because the
difference between male and female
emerged biologically
hundreds and hundreds of millions of
years ago there's almost no more
fundamental perceptual category or what
would you call it conceptual structure
of orientation then the difference
between male and female partly because
if you're not capable of perceiving it
you won't reproduce
and that's the end of that and so the
notion that this is somehow a social
construct is so delusional that it's
almost it's it's surreal it's beyond
surreal it's it's surreal to the point
of incomprehensibility and there's an
arrogance about it that is
um luciferian its magnitude the idea
that we can subvert the entire natural
order to the subjective whim of children
is absolutely Preposterous and it must
have been so how did you feel when your
son came home and started asking you
these questions what what effect did
that have on you had a great effect and
not to mention what he was saying there
was lots of things going on he asked me
if he could be this person's friend but
one of the things he brought up was that
they were in gym class and they were
getting split up by girls and boys so
this child was now with the girls and
his friend was making a lot of comments
about that and that concerned me about
bullying so I went ahead and I read
their bullying handbook and it did not
say anything about misgendering and I
went and called the school psychologist
now I called the school psychologist
without trying to give my son's name
because I didn't think that was relevant
to what was going on but I needed to
understand if misgendering would be
considered bullying because we have kids
being these are 10 year olds okay so
they're not on any sort of hormone
blockers this is just affirming bite
name and I asked her if it would be
considered uh bullying and she gave me
quite a bit of
a pushback and she was accusing me of
saying that this was a social contagion
which
you know I which it is which it is right
100 she demanded that I tell her who I
was speaking of and I said with all due
respect
are you telling me that you how many
male to female 10 year olds are at your
school and she said define a lot and
that was the end of the conversation to
me how many kids are doing this and I
said to her so let me ask you a question
in fifth grade we we split up the
children and we put them in a class
according to their assigned sex
and they learn about the period or what
happens to the male are you going to be
allowing this child to go into the
females with that and she said yes and I
said that you have no idea that
dysphoria you will cause that child when
they are sitting in that room and
learning about the periods and they are
never going to have the period and we
are telling them but hey you're a female
that is so scary
and so and so things like that is just
how did she respond with female
psychologist you were talking to how did
she respond to that very aggressively
and she told me at the end I said you
might want to get a policy she said it
would be considered bullying according
to intent and I said with all due
respect right intent yeah how is it a 10
year old went to school with this kid
since kindergarten as a boy and now
you're telling them it's a girl it's
like a toilet and a shelf just because
you poop on the Shelf does not make a
toilet and they do not understand you're
not even presenting to them the concept
of being transgender my son did not know
what that was until then and I had to
explain that to them because we have
kids thinking they can wake up and feel
a different way feelings are very
sensual
and this is not very good to keep going
on is his feelings
yeah well you know the like let's talk
about the American Psychological
Association guidelines for standard of
care so
one of the great advantages to the
practice of Clinical Psychology was it's
grounding in the research domain and so
if you were trained as a clinical
psychologist under the boulder model you
were required to be trained as a
clinician but also as a researcher and
that meant that you learned how to
analyze the scientific literature which
by the way is not the case for
Physicians and it's generally not the
case for clinicians who aren't trained
under the boulder model but if you learn
to think scientifically there's certain
conclusions that you're obliged to draw
as a consequence of that training and
one of the conclusions and this is
conclusions that are well instantiated
on the ethical front is that multiple
techniques of measurement are required
before you can formalize a diagnosis and
so if you're trying to understand
someone's problem to diagnose them let's
say one of the sources of information
that you use is self-report and
self-report is essentially it's not
entirely reducible to feelings but it's
that's where you would put feelings
you'd put feelings and thoughts all
subjective identification no I feel so
for example
if you're diagnosing someone who's
anorexic they're going to tell you that
they feel fat now if you used only their
feelings as the diagnostic marker you'd
have to conclude that they're fat but of
course if you have any sense as a
clinician you'd note that if they're
severely anorexic not only are they not
fat but they're probably going to die of
starvation and so but the point I'm
making here is that we're already bound
as clinicians
who are research trained under the APA
protocols to use multiple methods of
measurement and so for example if you
wanted to clarify the nature of
someone's so-called identity you'd use
self-report but you'd use objective
diagnostic markers and sometimes that's
questionnaires and there's other ways of
going about it there's behavioral
logging for example you can track
people's behavior you do that if you
were diagnosing people for depression
you might have them fill out a mood
inventory every hour every day for two
or three weeks and look at the variation
in their patterns you'd use
well-validated objective questionnaires
to and there's a whole method for
deriving those and then you might also
get
gather information from family or
friends or or let's say
significantly involve professionals so
for example if you're assessing
childhood behavior in the classroom
trying to diagnose children for for uh
attention deficit disorder conduct
disorder you might get the child self
report you might get reports from their
friends you might get reports from their
teachers you might get reports from
their parents and then what you look for
is Convergence across measures and if
you have convergence across multiple
measures then you assume something like
diagnostic accuracy now just as a
sidebar for everyone watching and
listening this is how you Orient
yourself in the world
okay you have five senses
they're qualitatively different so
hearing and seeing are not the same and
hearing and seeing are quite different
from tasting they're completely separate
biological systems and they use
different sampling approaches and what's
happened evolutionarily is that we've
converged on a five-dimensional solution
we essentially believe that if something
is reported to you by five different
measurement techniques that's your five
senses that that
phenomenon is real
no now
that isn't even good enough because
we're so
it's so difficult to specify what's real
that we also not only use our senses to
evaluate the world but then we go talk
to other people and see if they see hear
taste and touch the same things right
because even with those five senses we
can get locked into an erroneous
subjectivity and we need consensus and
then empirical testing to ensure that
we're not deluding ourself and that's
when we're trying to strive for the
truth if we're trying to delude
ourselves for our for underground
psychological purposes let's say things
become even more complex so the reason
I'm going down this pathway is to lay
out for those who are listening the fact
that it's already been established by
by uh properly ethically oriented and
well-trained clinicians that you have a
primary ethical responsibility to use
the reliable and valid means of
diagnosis that are at your disposal and
that means that you are ethically bound
not to rely on subjective
self-evaluation it's one input but it
does not override the others and the
fact that we've about faced on that
partly because of legislative pressure
but also because of ideological idiocy
is absolutely 100 percent by the
standards of the profession itself an
ethical transgression
and so okay so now we're letting kids
no we're mandated to encourage children
to assume that they're only what they
are as a consequence of their day-to-day
subjective self-evaluation right and
there's nothing stable about that either
because the additional claim is not only
are you only who you say you are or feel
you are whatever the hell feel means
but that can switch at your choice at
any moment and no one has anything to
say about that as well under threat of
punishment of Law and then we think well
are we confusing children it's like well
not only are they being confused as a
consequence of that we're setting out to
confuse them as deeply as we possibly
could
so and I think one of the big things I
want to talk about too is there was a
push an accord like as I was doing this
that even diagnos diagnosing them with
gender dysphora about dysphoria wasn't
accurate or the best terminology because
this is a choice I mean that's one of my
concerns around this is that we really
have gotten away from hey we are
treating people of severe mental illness
like someone was going through this has
severe pathology happening now it's just
if you choose and that I mean when I
started they was not a thing and a lot
of people that I do know that are trans
actually think that that discredits
their belief and supervising interns
that come in and have children that say
on Monday and Tuesday I feel like a boy
and then on Wednesday and Friday I feel
like a girl
I don't know what word what that means
and what we're talking about anymore and
and just you know well we might want to
delve into that too it's like
you know people will say something like
I feel let's say I feel like I'm in the
wrong body or I feel like I'm a boy but
I feel like a girl and then you think
well what do you exactly mean by that
well on the I don't feel like I'm in the
wrong body front that means detailed
analysis it's like well exactly what it
is about your current physiology that
causes you distress like precisely what
it is what is it so in Chloe Cole's case
for example it turned out that her
fundamental problem was that she wasn't
going to have the kind of curvy figure
that she had viewed as ideal for a woman
now that's a lot different than I feel
like a boy correct right but if you
don't delve into that carefully you're
never going to get to the bottom of it
and then on the on the subjective
feeling front it's like well what the
hell do you mean that you feel like
you're a boy if you're a girl first of
all how do you know that because you
don't have privileged access to what it
what it constitutes to feel like a boy
whatever that means it's not even
technically possible for you except in
the realm of fantasy you know like I
could imagine what it might be like to
be a girl now let's delve into that a
little bit so when my son was a kid he
was about two
and his sister was three and a half and
she had little cotary of friends you
know and they used to get together and
dress up and they often for a period of
time dressed my son Julian up in these
little girl costumes you know like
really feminine costumes fairy wings and
like a little tutu and and they had
quite the time
um
playing out this game and he would come
upstairs and you know zip about and
they'd chase him and so forth and I was
watching that thinking okay what the
hell's going on here because there was
part of me that I had some discomfort
about that and so I thought okay what's
Happening Here a why is he doing it B
why are the girls doing it C why am I
uncomfortable with it
okay so I started with my own discomfort
because I thought well you know is
something going on here that you should
intervene in or not or is it about you
and I talk to my wife about that and as
we laid it out I realized that
a young boy has to play out being a girl
in fantasy and a young girl has to play
out being a boy because unless you play
it out build a fictional representation
you can't understand the opposite sex
and so then I thought oh I see what's
going on he's just playing out being a
girl and the girls are playing with the
idea of sex and they're trying to
calibrate what it's like to be the
opposite sex and what it's like to be
them and that's perfectly within the
bounds of acceptable pretend play now
one of the concerns I have at the moment
is that
our kids are so involved with screens
that a lot of that early pretend play
where sexual identity is truly
established is actually being completely
interfered with and I think a lot of
what we're seeing on the Adolescent
front is the re-emergence of that
fantasy play that was always suppressed
but in any case yeah I have a similar
story journal with my son he you know
was playing with Hilo on him to play
with dolls and Barbies and
I was obviously okay with that and I
remember asking him like why don't we
buy Eric like the prince for Ariel and
he said to me oh
I don't want to play with boys boys are
mean and I was like oh okay so this is
how he was understanding the world and
you know he's a little older now he
doesn't really play Barbies anymore but
I was like okay this is how they're
playing out and how he is representing
how he understands women and and himself
and
I see a lot of parents I mean I'm not
gonna lie to you the moment my kid
played with Barbies I had to have the
thought as a parent would I be okay if
my son was a girl and where did that
come from and I don't think our our
parents our parents didn't worry about
that I see my friends have to like okay
I would accept if my child is this other
gender and that is in itself bizarre
that we're going down that path
we'll be right back first we wanted to
give you a sneak peek at Jordan's new
series Exodus
so the Hebrews created history as we
know it
you don't get away with anything and so
you might think you can bend the fabric
of reality and that you can treat people
instrumentally and that you can bow to
the Tyrant and violate your conscience
without cost you will pay the piper it's
going to call you out of that slavery
into Freedom even if that pulls you into
the desert
and we're going to see that there's
something else going on here that is far
more Cosmic and deeper than what you can
imagine the highest
[Music]
Spirit to which we're beholden is
presented precisely as that spirit that
allies itself with the cause of Freedom
against tyranny I want villains to get
punished but do you want the villains to
learn before they have to pay the
ultimate price that's such a Christian
question
so one of the biggest Liars lies on The
Butchery and liar front is the is the
following would you rather have a trans
child or a dead child
and that really really to say it annoys
me is to say almost nothing and here's
here's the technical reason so in the
API guidelines for gender affirming care
there are two contradictory claims being
put forward it's very interesting to
read the document because the first
claim is that
because of prejudice amongst researchers
against the transgender Community there
are no valid long-term follow-up studies
of the mental health of transitioning
people across the lifespan okay so
that's quite the claim because first of
all this is such a new phenomenon that
it's no wonder that there are no
long-term studies and the fact that
there are no long no long-term studies
might be tangentially related in some
small degree to Prejudice among the
research Community which is about the
least prejudiced Community that's ever
existed on the planet by the way but but
it's it's Preposterous to assume that
the dearth of long-term follow-up
studies is a consequence of mere
Prejudice it's just well it's a new
phenomenon that's the basic explanation
but the admission is there are no
well-documented reliable and valid
long-term follow-up studies okay then
three pages later the claim is
well unless you allow people or
facilitate people to transform early
their mental health will be impaired to
the point where their suicide risk is
elevated I thought okay wait a second
here one of those claims can be true
even though neither of them are but both
of them cannot be true simultaneously
there are either valid long-term studies
documenting the mental health
consequences of transitioning or they're
not or there aren't
and the evidence is either
pro-transition or anti now the truth of
the matter is that the research that
would be necessary to establish the
truth of the proposition that early
transition has mental health benefits
has by no means been done and it's also
Complicated by the fact and this is a
true complication that testosterone
itself has pharmacological
antidepressant properties so if you give
dysphoric young women testosterone or
dysphoric young men for that matter then
they do feel better but it's not because
they're transitioning it's because of
the biochemical consequences of
testosterone so it's a bloody mess but
the idea that we actually know that
early transitioning for kids with
so-called gender dysphoria is beneficial
to their mental health that is an utter
lie there is not a there is not one
shred of it now it's worse than that
because
and this is
clinicians who are properly trained
should have known this so this is
something else I want to delve into so
the broadest category of psychopathology
the the vaguest and most inclusive
category is probably something like the
Nexus between depression and anxiety
right it's intense negative emotion
virtually no one comes into the
therapeutic milieu who isn't suffering
from intense negative emotion okay and
there are a multitude of reasons why you
would suffer from intense negative
emotion and some of those are biological
circadian rhythm disruptions physical
illness uh onset of puberty trait
neuroticism which is a huge contributor
which is also elevated among women
compared to men which is why women have
five times the rate of depressive and
anxiety disorders cross-culturally
there's lots of reasons to be miserable
now if you're miserable
that's amorphous because you're
miserable and you're confused and so in
some sense you don't know how to be
miserable and that's where the cultural
issue starts to become Paramount so if
you go back to Freud's time for example
there was a subset of women in Europe
who were miserable hysterically Hysteria
by the way meant wandering uterus that's
the derivation of the term and sometimes
removal of the uterus was cure for cure
for hysteria it's very much analogous to
what's going on now and hysteria took on
a very narrowly culturally defined
pathway so hysterical women were very
dramatic and the Victorian culture was
very theatrical especially in the upper
Ash class echelons where hysteria was
more uh probable just like anorexia was
more common among you know upper middle
class girls in particular and so it was
very theatrical it involved a lot of
shortness of breath it involved physical
weakness and it involved sort of
dramatic fainting and that became a uh
psychological epidemic hysteria and then
there's waves of psychological epidemics
they happen very frequently probably
about one a generation as it turns out
and there's a literature
tracing the outbreak of psychogenic
epidemics going back 300 years the
master document on that front is a book
called uh the discovery of the
unconscious by Henri Ellen Berger which
is an absolutely brilliant book an
analysis of 350 years of clinical
Endeavor a brilliant book anyways
when the pronoun
controversy first emerged I told the
Canadian Senate that if we mocked about
with these fundamental categories we
were going to produce a psychological
epidemic because I knew this literature
when you are being trained back in your
20s
did anybody ever talk to you about the
the existence of psychological epidemics
not once and not hysteria not contagion
nothing
no okay so so we could we could list
them out as they've manifested
themselves over the last five decades so
cutting was a psychological epidemic
anorexia was a psychological epidemic
bulimia was a psychological epidemic
um there was a satanic daycare abuse
Scandal epidemic in the 1980s
and that's well that covers about the
last 60 years so that's a lot of
psychological epidemics and it turns out
to be the case that the people most
prone to psychogenic epidemics are
pubertal girls
now why that is I don't know you know I
think maybe it's because girls hit
puberty earlier than boys
and so they're not as prepared let's say
neurologically to deal with the rapid
demand for maturation that puberty
imposes upon them but also that with
puberty with girls you get an increase
in negative emotion and body sensitivity
so maybe that's what tilts girls in that
direction but we don't know but boys are
less prone to that contagion for
whatever reason and so it's certainly
the case that the most accurate
diagnostic
um
decision with relationship to the
massive explosion of so-called gender
dysphoria in the last five years is that
it's another example of social contagion
but you said when you were trained that
none of that literature was even you
weren't even exposed to it so you didn't
know that that was even a possibility
not at all in our you know again be way
before social media takes off you know
that that's not there either where
the guidelines were out there so no
okay so have you developed any expertise
in the intervening years about
psychological epidemics psychogenic
epidemics oh absolutely and I think
that's a big piece of why I sort of
stepped away and one of the things I did
notice when I was doing the training in
adults I would say my so I did
do both adults and children in my
practice right I would say primarily I
went with children because that's the
fastest growing career at that time but
when I was doing it when I was doing
adults um the percentage of male to
female I would say it was 80 percent
male to female in adults
whereas it's the opposite with kids so
when I treated
and that's I think why one of your
letters was even more profound it was
eighty percent of the kids I treated
were born female
and and one of the and one of the things
that
again that's difficult about this is
that we can't have conversations around
this and why wouldn't I see such an
increase happening in adults if this was
happening if this is accepted and the
literature is out there I would expect
that I would see a great increase of
adults identifying as this and I did not
see that
so so one of the counter one of the
counter claims that's been put forward
with some degree of insistence in recent
years is that we're not seeing a
psychogenic epidemic what we're seeing
instead is the fact that there was a lot
more variability in sexual identity than
the oppressive patriarchal culture had
allowed to make manifest and now that
we've taken off the restrictions people
are just reverting or a lot or a lot
they're now allowed or encouraged to
express their true identity and so
that's actually accessible because
imagine now that we have a lot more
people who are claiming
um attraction to both sexes on the
sexual front now what you should see as
a consequence of that is that the rates
of
cross-sex sexual contact have would
increase right but what's happening
instead as far as I've been able to tell
is that although up to 20 percent of
young people now claim an identity
somewhere on the LGBT Spectrum LGBT plus
and definitely the plus is the you know
the crucial issue there they claim
identity on the LGBT plus Spectrum but
if you look at their actual sexual
behavior that hasn't changed a bit so
for example most girls who claim to be
bisexual for example have have only
sexual experience to the degree that
they have any with boys that hasn't
moved at all and so that's very
interesting to me it's actually quite
surprising because I would have thought
that the psychological pressure
would have been sufficient to not only
move identity claims but actually to
move Behavior to some degree you know at
least to increase experimentation but
that actually doesn't seem to be the
case which is more evidence that that
initial orientation gender orientation
and sexual orientation is you know much
more solidly set than the social
constructionists certainly and I think
what one of my things that I want to
point out is I really felt that I was
signing off on agreeing for a medical
intervention not an identity and that's
what we're signing off on now and and I
do think it's very unique that this is
the only Medical
thing I sign off on for children in my
field there is not one other Medical
diagnosis that I can give to a child
that would give them medical treatment
and we aren't trained for that and let
alone what they are coming back with you
know in terms of cancer and sexual
issues and they are not going to receive
orgasm and most therapists aren't ready
to talk about that with the typical
client let alone someone who now had can
takes 25 minutes to drop urine in the
bathroom now after post-surgery
so I just don't even think we understand
what we're doing
right absolutely it's one of the things
that shocked me when I first interviewed
Abigail schreier because I'm a
reasonably well-educated clinician but I
am not a physician and so I didn't
really understand the full ramifications
or even the full extent of what's being
referred to euphemistically in this
pathological manner as bottom and top
surgery
I didn't realize for example that in
order to construct a penis that will
never work properly by the way either as
an organ of excretion or an organ of
sexual pleasure or reproduction that the
victim's arm is going to be stripped of
its musculature essentially right down
to the bone leaving nothing for about a
five inch piece except bone covered with
skin so that the muscles can be
harvested so that a dysfunctional penis
equivalent can be fabricated and that's
just one of the cataclysmic consequences
of the full surgical nightmare nor do
they understand that and nor do they
understand I've had to teach people
who are going to be
of presenting as male who want to have
sex with males and I have to explain to
them you know you have a cervical spine
and sex will be different they don't
understand that these kids that are
doing it they have no idea that they
won't have functional
reproductive organs anymore well and
with with with Chloe Cole for example we
delved into the issue of of breast
reconstruction so she had a double
mastectomy when she was 15. now the
double mastectomies first of all I do
believe they're a cardinal Act of
unforgivable Butchery I think that
people who have done that to minors
should be put in prison that's my belief
now here's partly why I mean first of
all you don't remove healthy body parts
from minors that's like let's make that
rule number one but the other issue
there is the sheer destructiveness of it
not only will those women
they're now they don't have breasts
they'll never be able to breastfeed
which is a real cataclysm for their
children because breastfeeding is
actually necessary for children let's
make that perfectly clear they develop
much better if they're breastfed they're
much more intelligent and they're more
bonded with their mother and that's a
crucial part of early development so
it's not something that can be
replaceable with formula so but
but in addition to that not only are the
breasts removed and then hypothetically
reconstructed but the nipples are
removed and then replaced now first of
all that might work and it might not and
in Cole's case it didn't work very well
because she never healed properly but it
also means that all the erotic potential
of that area has now been permanently
sacrificed and that's a major loss I
mean there aren't that many primary
sources of pleasure in life and to
eradicate someone's capability for
erotic pleasure in that manner in this
high-handed way at the age of 15 is
absolutely well I think it's absolutely
unforgivable I think it's criminally
unforgivable and especially given that
it's been rushed you know and I'd also
like to point out for everyone who's
listening just to make sure that this is
as dark as it can possibly be because it
should be is that you know different
professions attract different kinds of
people and so in media entertainment and
um politics
a disproportionate number of narcissists
are attracted now that doesn't mean that
everybody in those domains is
narcissistic although that's a risk what
it does mean is that if you are a
narcissistic
you're going to gravitate towards
professions where there's a lot of
public attention
okay so let's think about
surgery for a moment now the upside of
surgery is that you get to be a surgeon
and that you can help people but the
downside of surgery is
you get to cut people up
now if you're particularly empathic the
probability that you're going to be a
surgeon is pretty damn low because if
you're particularly empathic the barrier
to having to make the hard decisions and
actually make incisions and that sort of
thing that's very that's very high
barrier on the empathy side so generally
speaking you're going to give surgeons
who are lower in empathy and that's not
necessarily a bad thing but the ultimate
extreme of that is that and this happens
in nursing as well and it happens in
child care and it happens in the care of
old people is that there is a
non-trivial percentage of people in
those occupations who have a sadistic
bet and if you don't think that's true
then well then you don't know you
certainly don't know enough to be a
therapist and you certainly don't know
enough to formulate policy properly and
I'm certainly not saying that all
surgeons are sadistic but I am saying if
you are sadistic and you have a medical
bent then surgery is a perfectly lovely
place to end up and I can't help but
Wonder in my darker moments just how
much underground pleasure The Butchers
are taking in precisely their Butchery
and so you know people might think well
do we really have to go there and the
answer is well when you're starting to
strip the forearm musculature all 15
year olds to build them a penis that
will never work and you're charging them
five hundred thousand dollars to do that
over their lifetime and you're putting
them on the medical Mill and you're
funding your goddamn Hospital not in not
in least as a consequence of these
surgical procedures then yes we have to
go there that Rachel Levine who's you
know the poster child for the trans
movement in the Biden White House has
his emails dark documenting his
rumination and concern about how to make
the medical transition process maximally
profitable have been well documented on
well in the public now and so if you
don't think greed is driving this this
kind of narrow greed allied with the
kind of sadism then
you're not thinking the other thing
that's happening too you can comment on
this maybe as a clinician is that you
know
when you make a cataclysmic decision in
your life like you're male and you think
I'm female and then you go and do what's
necessary to transform yourself into a
nurse that's female there's going to be
a big part of you that has some major
doubts and that's never going to go away
and you could deal with those doubts
honestly and accept it as a cost of your
decision or you could do this you could
decide to go out and beat the drum about
just how right you were and you could
push that all the way to the point where
you're now convincing children that it
would be in their best interest to do
exactly what you did instead of facing
up to the fact that you know maybe you
have some qualms about your radical
decision and so that's rationalization
and justification
externalization also all of that mostly
rationalization and that can become
unbelievably pathological and I
certainly see that in the so-called
trans Community it's like well not only
are we like this but everyone should be
like this including children and I see
that I also see that kind of insanely
narcissistic Psychopathology emerging on
the drag queen Story Hour front because
what I see when I look at that with a
clinician's eye is that you have
narcissistic mothers in particular
who are
drama dramatically portraying their
creative openness and their compassion
by exposing their children to
adult males who are Auto gynophilic who
are dressed up in lingerie who are
dancing seductively in front of them as
a display of their of the mother's moral
virtue and that's that's Munchausen by
proxy for all intents and purposes and
of course I would also be curious when
you were trained as a
therapist to begin with did your
instructors ever talk to you about
munchos and syndrome or munchos and by
proxy no and I had to come across that
later in my practice which is really
what that was kind of the final case
where I saw
in front of me a mother really present
this for her child and in a way that you
know I think if you spoke to can you
talk about that a bit so I know you
can't you know yeah
um dispense with with confidentiality
but what did you see yeah I mean so
first of all
a parent presenting the case was a very
unique situation of this is how it's
happened this is how my kid presented
and the kid not being able to articulate
the same story but going along with it
and and I will tell you I mean for
anybody who is struggling with mental
health a lot of times when you get a
diagnosis there's a freedom in that
there's a oh yeah at least I know what's
going on so I don't think we good at
that when we give them an answer they
that makes them feel good at least I
know what's happening so for a kid I saw
him
like being taught what was happening to
him instead of it was already happening
to him
and this was this was a very wild case
in where I suggested to hold back and
wait on giving them hormones and the
courts over overrode what I said and the
doctors went ahead even though I
suggested to hold and that father lost
his rights and um ultimately did take
his life
yeah well look you could imagine so
here's the here's the terrible edible
situation so imagine that you have a
mother who's very immature narcissistic
right then she has a child who
manifests some forms of misbehavior as
old children do but maybe a little bit
more extreme you know and then the woman
is casting about for reasons why her
relationship with her child is Disturbed
which is causing her suffering well the
especially if she's narcissistic and
immature the easy route out of that is
to assume that there's something
fundamentally wrong with the child
okay now now then you Ally that with the
narcissistic desire for unwarranted
status and the mother learns very
rapidly that if her child is trans
that's pretty damn trendy and cool and
she can get a reputation among her local
community for being incredibly
Progressive and compassionate and caring
and she can shine in her virtue so I'll
give an example of this
when Ron DeSantis went after Disney
one of the Disney Executives uh there
was a there was a video that was
released where a number of Disney
Executives were talking about their
um efforts to push the LGBT plus agenda
using the Disney entertainment apparatus
and this woman who if I remember
correctly was in charge of domestic
programming for Disney very well
situated
in the corporate
um uh c-suite
office and she said
in the video that she had a
five-year-old and a seven-year-old
and one of them was trans
and the other was pansexual okay and so
then I did a quick
statistical calculation okay so the
probability that as a given mother that
you would have a trans child truly trans
by the definitions of 20 years ago is
one in three thousand approximately
and the probability that you'd have a
pansexual child whatever the hell that
is because that only emerged like three
years ago is obviously less than one in
three thousand but let's call it one in
three thousand okay The Joint
probability that you would have a trans
child and a pansexual child is one in
nine million
and so what that means diagnostically is
if you were evaluating that women woman
and her children you would have a two
million 999
999 to one probability that you are
accurate if you diagnosed her as
narcissistic
right so
what is it nine million it's sorry it's
8 million 999
999. it's one chance in nine million
that she's not a narcissist
right now narcissism in the general
population like at clinical levels
probably afflicts about four percent of
people
so four percent of mothers let's say
have that tilt towards narcissism and
there's going to be a substantial
proportion of them
one-tenth maybe God only knows what it
is who are perfectly willing to
sacrifice their children to their
narcissistic delusions and now that's
not only being enabled by therapists
it's been demanded by lawmakers that
therapists enable that and so that's the
so you add would you rather have a trans
child or a dead child and Chloe Cole's
parents got caught in that trap and
that's terrifying for parents you know
if they're facing severe distress on the
part of their children and a medical
professional says well you know you're
pretty Prejudiced and if you just drop
the Prejudice your child won't cut their
throat and so you have a trans child and
that'll be a problem but better than
them being dead so they're terrified out
of their skull on that front and then
you add the narcissism problem to that
and then you add the fact that now
therapists are mandated by law to do
gender affirmation care and you add the
sadism and greed of the people on the
medical side well you have a perfect
storm in relationship to producing a
psychological epidemic and so that's
exactly what we have on our hands and I
do want to say this and I I hope it
doesn't get me in trouble and I'm sure
that
people will come and have the opposite
to say one thing I will note say in with
this obsessed session with identity if
this is really going on I would see this
increase across races
I didn't
the majority of this is happening to
White
Caucasians and I can't yeah well you
know that's that's a strange thing eh
because the same was true for anorexia
and bulimia yeah you know it was not
only
and it's an it's an interesting thing to
speculate yeah you know because it's not
obvious why that is
um we know that more liberal white girls
are much more likely to be depressed and
anxious and I think so maybe maybe the
link with dysphoria is that
radically unconstrained freedom is
destabilized yes right you know so
here's an example if you have a
three-year-old kid and maybe they have
30 outfits in their closet and you open
the door and you say you can pick
whatever you want the child will also
often be confused by that and so and if
you say look you have to wear this then
they'll be annoyed yes but if you lay
like three outfits on the table on the
bed and you say which of those do you
like the child will pick one and be
perfectly happy now there's a consumer
Choice literature like that too so you
might imagine imagine you go to the
pharmacy and you have only one shampoo
to buy
well you're not very happy about that
because there's one damn shampoo I mean
who cares really but you get the point
now imagine instead that there were 200
you think well that's great look at all
the choice but what you find is
well if there's 200 shampoos the
probability that you pick the best
shampoo is zero because like what the
hell do you know about shampoo and so it
turns out that there's this Nexus where
there's the proper amount of choice and
it's a choice between a couple of
Alternatives this is what you do when
you play a game you know when you play
chess you can't use a basketball
but there's some things you can do with
just the right amount and the problem
with the radical liberal subjective whim
identity theory is that people drown in
possibility it's like well who are you
you're telling you you can be anything
you want what do you mean do you mean
anything you mean anything do you mean I
can be a girl do you mean I can be a boy
can I be both can I be neither can I
change that moment to moment Yes dear
you can be anything can I be a pussycat
now you talked about furries let's talk
about that for a minute what have you
seen on that front yes and I actually
got a lot of pushback off of this small
piece in the documentary
um yeah I have kids coming to schools
and teachers saying we're not doing
anything because they're saying it's a
queer identity now again I hear from the
queer
individuals that they do not own the
furries so I want to make that very
clear right now but they are coming to
school with Tails and meowing and there
is a subgroup and I don't think people
really understand the dangerous slope of
these chat rooms and these
these these rooms and you talked about a
little bit earlier one of the scarier
new trends I'm seeing is human sacrifice
coming up and talking about it kids are
playing Human Sacrifice out with dolls
and and you know I've seen exorcisms and
stuff but where are they learning this
and it's actually being taught through
uh rituals in the LGBT community and
through these chat rooms so
these cosplay personas that they're
taking on again this focused on identity
who are you and
they are saying a lot of that does look
like again that looks like
pathologically suppressed pretend play
you know uh jacquesep noted when he was
studying the development of play in in
rats that if you deprived juvenile males
in particular of the opportunity to
engage in rough and tumble play that
number one their prefrontal cortexes
wouldn't mature number two they were
hyperactive and number three that if you
then allowed them to play they would
play extremely intensely and
aggressively in an attempt to catch up
so imagine in these situations what
you're getting is rebound pretend play
is that kids have been deprived to
pretend play early and so when they find
these virtual forums where they can
engage in fantasy
you know too much later than should have
occurred from a developmental
perspective that that can just go
completely astray you know I think the
autoginophilia that characterizes these
40 year old men is a form of repressed
Pretend Play Now by that time it becomes
sexualized you know when kids are three
and four there's not a lot of sexual
impetus in their pretend play there's
some but not much but if it's suppressed
until adolescence or later then well the
sexual element is also going to gonna
gonna what what do you say make itself
make itself manifest and these are also
things that we understand virtually not
at all let me close with with another
question okay and uh
well look you went into the therapy
business as an empathic person with some
interest in in the domain of sexual
behavior and you strived to work as a
compassionate person and to do what you
could to act in the best interests of
people who let's say were marginalized
and that went astray
why
and and what do you think what do you
want to tell
want to be therapists and currently
practicing therapists about what you've
learned and about how they should adjust
their attitudes and behavior accordingly
oh a lot um
I guess I would say to therapists is to
really give informed
consent and think about that element of
practice and what does it mean to inform
someone about their sexual reproduction
their mental emotional health I mean not
to mention
95 of these patients will be at
antidepressants for the rest of their
lives
and the training of that
um that we've talked to each other I
think the scariest thing is is that this
isn't safe to talk about and now we are
signing off on someone's identity for
the rest of their life
and just being able to have
a dialogue where
we have to now discuss the transitioners
I don't think we even understand the
implications for most of these people
are going to have cancer within 15 years
I mean when you
engage in hormones that is the risk and
that is what we're telling people
so we are telling people that the way to
be validated which by the way will only
be outside life is
to get affirmation
um to teach kids one of the things I've
heard more recently is people that are
transitioning are not being honest to
Physicians about their real assigned sex
so they are going into procedures not
telling doctors their gender so they are
getting prescribed potentially harmful
medications and really neglecting their
health so just
advising people Sarah one other
questions yeah so now you participated
in this documentary you had met wolf
documentary and now you're also talking
to me and this is going to cause you a
substantial amount of grief and so why
why have you done it what has it done
for you to decide that you were willing
to speak out about this I mean because
there's huge risk associated with it
first of all you have to admit that in
many ways you were misinformed to begin
with and that that had some pretty net
devastating consequences for you
personally but for other people and
that's a bitter pill to swallow but
you're also exposing yourself to all
sorts of well critical commentary and
allegations of betrayal and transphobian
and hatred like why are you doing this
and what has doing this done for you
um I'm doing it for our children I think
they deserve the truth and they deserve
the best outcomes possible I think even
if you speak to people who are trans
they would tell you that intervening at
a young age is not the best and we
should maybe really reconsider this
um
I have I'm not gonna lie
personally felt
very bad
that I was a part of this in a part of
realizing how quickly it became of how I
was put in a position to affirm medical
procedures that would impact them for
the rest of their life they are not
allowed to get those medical procedures
without a therapist ladder so there was
no choice
um
I would I would have parents I would
tell parents to
get a second opinion with this with what
they're doing to their children
and to continue to get help and
just that I feel like I'm gonna spend
the rest of my life fighting for
children not to be butchered anymore
okay well thank you very much for
talking me today for everybody watching
and listening I'm going to talk to Sarah
for an additional half an hour on the
daily wire plus platform I want to walk
through the early stages of her career
in the development of her interests and
so we'll we'll do that on the daily word
plus side um so thank you to all of you
who are listening and watching and
thanks Sarah for well you know this is
land this is a field of landmines that
we're walking through and so you know
kudos to you for having enough
courage I suppose desperation as well to
say what you've observed to be the case
in this forthright manner and hopefully
it'll do some good yes and likely it
will and hopefully you won't
pay a price that's
too high for doing it you know and I
hope that you can reconcile yourself to
the current situation and
and uh you know put your conscience in
order yes that would be good yes and so
all right so thank you everyone for
watching listening to the film crew here
in
um Regina Saskatchewan is where I'm here
today thank you for facilitating this
and to the Daily work plus people for
making this conversation possible it's
much appreciated and so ciao till next
time everyone
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com